so ist es wirklich auf dem mars passend
zum film der marsianer haben wir heute
für euch die fünf verblüffendsten fakten
über den mars inklusive expertenwissen
in den kinos startet jetzt der film der
marsianer und es ist die bisher
realistischste darstellung des
erdnächsten planeten in unserem
sonnensystem
das bestätigt die geologin daniela tisch
beim deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr die ich in berlin
interviewt haben also erstaunlicherweise
finde ich das buch und dem film sehr nah
an einer potenziellen realität wie sie
von uns in der zukunft tatsächlich mal
so sein könnte technisch gesehen sind
wir dazu heute absolut nicht in der lage
aber die ideen die hinter der
realisierung stecken die sind doch sehr
nah an dem was wohl irgendwann mal
möglich sein wird das fängt schon bei
der route von marc widmann und auch die
techniken die er einsetzt um dort zu
überleben sind wissenschaftlich fundiert
letzte woche berichteten wir ja über
wasser auf dem mars im film hat es mit
dem mit noch nicht verwenden können bei
dieser fund noch nicht bekannt war
glückwunsch an alle bei der nasa das
sind großartige neuigkeiten ich wünschte
mir dass ich das gewusst hätte als ich
auf dem mars gestrandet war aber beim
nächsten mal wenn ich da feststeckte
weil sich dass es dort wasser gibt
dieses video hat matt damon auf twitter
gepostet aber nicht nur dass es dort
wasser gibt ist ein verblüffender fakt
über den roten planeten beginnen wir mit
dem ersten von fünf fakten und steigern
uns dann von fakt so fakt beginnen wir
mit dem ersten fakt und steigern uns
dann von fakt sei fakt wenn ihr auf der
erde die rede von einem vulkan ist dann
spricht man häufig von der größenordnung
eines durchschnittlichen berges auf dem
mars sieht das ganz anders aus dort
steht der vulkan olympus mons an der
breitesten stelle misst dieser ganze 600
kilometer und sein kater hat
durchmesser von 50 kilometern zudem ist
der vulkan gute 25 kilometer hoch ein
wahrer koloss zum vergleich der höchste
vulkan auf der erde der ojos del salado
ist 6885 meter hoch stapelt man den
höchsten berg auf der erde und jetzt
aufgepasst gemessen vom tiefsten punkt
aus ist es nämlich nicht der mount
everest sondern der mauna kea auf hawaii
mehr als dreieinhalb mal übereinander
erst dann erhält man die höhe des
olympus mons olympus mons ist der größte
vulkan im sonnensystem noch der größte
vulkan auf dem mars und er kann so groß
werden weil es auf dem mars keine
erosionsprozess gibt keine abtragung
prozesse kein wind kein regen kein
wasser gar nichts was ihnen der wieder
abtragen ist das heißt alles was auf dem
mars wächst kann unendlich hoch wachsen
linda prozesse lange genug gedauert ohne
wieder abgetragen zu werden
es wird meteorologisch fakt 2 bringt die
römische mythologie beziehungsweise die
griechische mit ins spiel
je nachdem wie man es sehen mag die
römer haben wir ein bisschen copy and
pace betrieben wie hier auf der erde
sehen jeden abend einen mond werden wir
auf dem mars zu hause hätten wir zwei
monde zu bestaunen
zwei maß monde beide tragen ein ganz
speziellen namen passen zum mars vor
boss und deimos phobos steht für furcht
und deimos für schrecken hintergrund
eben die mythologie mars ist der
kriegsgott und hat an seiner seite
furcht und schrecken
focus ist rund 9000 kilometer vom mars
entfernt und weinhaus 23.000 und groß
sind sie nicht sehr
sie haben nämlich also voraus einen
durchmesser von 26 kilometern und deimos
von 16 kilometern also ziemlich winzig
so unterschiedlich und doch sogleich der
dritte akt dreht sich um den besonderen
jahres zyklus des roten planeten
im video leben auf dem mars berichteten
wir dass der mars ähnlich wie die erde
jahreszeiten durchläuft allerdings
dauern sie deutlich länger als hier auf
der erde der maas hat eine deutlich
längere umlaufzeit um die sonne
trotz des beinahe gleichen
neigungswinkels von rund 25 grad der
mars beziehungsweise erdachse dauert der
frühling auf der erde und 93 tagen auf
dem mars dauert er fast doppelt so lang
170 tage
der sommer ist die längste jahreszeit
auf dem mars und 196 tage und hier auf
der erde sind nur 94 tage
und obwohl auf dem mars ist eigentlich
immer eisig kalt ist ist der winter nur
145 tage lang bei uns sind es 89 tage
und ja so unterschiedlich langen die
jahreszeit dauern so ähnlich sind die
tageslänge der mars dreht sich also fast
so schnell um die eigene achse wie die
ehre ein tag auf dem mars dauert etwa 40
minuten länger als hier auf der erde
aber warum dauern die jahreszeiten dann
aber so viel länger als auf der erde
eben grund ist der umkreis förmige weg
die elliptische bahn um die sonne und
die bewirkt dann wiederum dass die
jahreszeiten so unterschiedlich lang
sind auf dem mars nach oben also in
richtung fakt 5 wird die luft immer
dünner die luft auf dem mars ist nämlich
extrem dünn hier auf der erde besteht
sie aus 78 prozent stickstoff 21 prozent
sauerstoff und der rest ist argon
kohlendioxid wasserstoff und so weiter
die luft auf dem mars besteht zu 95
prozent aus kohlendioxid allerdings ist
der luftdruck sehr niedrig so dass nur
ein prozent der dichte im vergleich zur
erdatmosphäre herz sprich da wo auf der
erde 100 moleküle sind ist es auf dem
mars nur ein einziges und hier ist auch
der einer der wenigen fehler im film
da die luft dort so dünn ist hat selbst
der heftigste sturm dort nur sehr
geringe auswirkungen
windgeschwindigkeiten von 100 kilometern
pro stunde
dort die wirkung von
windgeschwindigkeiten von einem
kilometer pro stunde
hier auf der erde also praktisch keine
bilder wie diese gibt es so nicht auf
dem mars bevor wir zu einem kleinen aber
sehr wichtigen extrakt kommen die
absolute sensation erwartet uns im
fünften akt flüssiges wasser auf dem
mars die nasa raumsonde mars
reconnaissance orbiter kurzem er hat
spuren von salzen raten gefunden
ein spektrometer genauer gesagt das
compact rekorde chance im magic
spektrometer zeichnete infrarot wählen
im bereich von 1,9 mikrometern auf diese
wellenlänge ist typisch für salz hydrate
und im board salz hydrate versteckt sich
auch schon die sensation
nitrate sind stoffe die meistens wasser
also aller meistens wasser enthalten das
heißt diese salz rückstände müssen in
verbindung mit flüssigem wasser aktuell
also jetzt in dieser zeit entstanden
sein es gibt also flüssiges wasser auf
dem mars
und jetzt der wichtige extra fakt und
wann werden wir endlich auf dem mars
landen die ersten versuche die laufen
bereits schon
ja es gibt tatsächlich experimente auf
der iss wo man untersucht wie pflanzen
unter schweren bedingungen wachsenden es
gibt experimente wo man unsere sophie
flechten
unter weltraumbedingungen überleben
können wie sie mit der kosmischen
strahlung auskommen das sind alles erste
schritte in auf einem weg zu einer
irgendwann mal bemannten mars-mission
aber da ist man schon an ersten
praktischen übungen dabei bis es aber
soweit ist können wir uns ein sehr
realistisches bild im film der marsianer
vom mars machen
ein mann völlig allein auf sich gestellt
versucht mit allen mitteln zu überlegen
währenddessen läuft eine extrem
risikoreiche mission team zu retten
angesichts der letzten entdeckung auf
dem mars ist das ein unheimlich
spannendes thema und damit ein klasse
film für alle science fiction fans und
alle die es noch werden wollen für alle
die sich genauer über die letzten
entdeckungen informieren wollen
da empfehle ich das letzte video leben
auf dem mars hier oben und ami zu rap
und zum blog geht es da auch hin
und ansonsten würde mich interessieren
was haltet ihr denn von dem film habt
ihr den trailer gesehen wart ihr schon
im kino und könntet ihr euch vorstellen
auf dem mars zu leben schreibt in den
kommentaren und damit bis dann bleibt
dran